[Music]
welcome back to curious archive this
video is the second half of a series
exploring the biology and ecosystems of
realistic pokemon the realistic pokemon
art project was created by the talented
rj palmer aka arvalis and i've links
below where you can follow and support
his work this second round of redesigns
features amazing biological details and
an even wider variety of pokemon but
please remember the disclaimer from the
first video these realistic life forms
are an exciting speculative exercise but
not an attempt to somehow improve the
stylized designs of the original games
they're just fun alternate takes that
imagine pokemon in something closer to
real world anatomy although of course
these life forms are more fantastical
than what would likely appear in nature
with that said let's jump into part 2 of
our nature documentary of another world
and return to the astonishing domain of
realistic pokemon
beginning with gen 2 starters we have
meganium in its pre-evolutions the
designs of these creatures take
inspiration from sauropods but also from
modern tortoises and while tortoises
have evolved to eat grasses palmer
imagines the long necks of meganium help
them reach their preferred food of
treetop fungi and speaking of fungi the
antenna at the end of meganium's
nostrils are actually a unique strain of
fungi which palmer states the titans
have a symbiotic relationship with
although the exact purpose of this is
unknown the flower-like structure on the
front of their shell is not a plant
however but a brightly colored frill
that mimics flower petals this might
seem strange but animals camouflaging
themselves as plants has been documented
numerous times in nature like insects
whose wings have evolved to resemble
leaves
up next we have typhlosion and its
pre-evolutions reimagined with greater
detail and anatomical plausibility in
its claws and fur pattern this
reimagining resembles a cross between
some sort of badger and a sun bear
palmer imagines typhlosion feeds
primarily on comb bee hives and the wax
from the hives has a chemical reaction
with typhlosion saliva to create a
flammable substance typhlosions then use
their tongues to coat their quills in
this chemical and then light them on
fire using specialized flint-like teeth
the blazing quills are an intimidating
display and can burn for long periods
thanks to typhlosion's fire resistant
coat a really original explanation and
the last starter from the hoenn region
is for alligator and its pre-evolutions
rendered in all their reptilian glory
not surprisingly fair alligator is most
analogous to earth alligators or
crocodiles palmer imagines this life
form as a large opportunistic carnivore
lurking in coastal estuaries and
frequently traveling between salt and
freshwater habitats i'd probably watch
my step near rivers with these giants
around moving beyond generation 2 we
have the incredible desert dwelling
flygon palmer envisions that this swift
aerial lifeform possesses a helium
bladder that helps the large organism
achieve flight fly guns skim the surface
of the desert looking out from behind a
red transparent membrane which protects
their eyes from the sands and on the
sands near some other interesting desert
fauna i'll let you classify on your own
we can find a trap pinch and a vibrava
both reimagined to look like they could
more feasibly be early stages in a
flygon's life cycle
in this alternative world millions of
years ago large prehistoric pokemon
stomped across the land now known to
scientists in the form of fossils taking
inspiration from the games palmer
imagines recent technology has revived
these long extinct species like the
mighty tyrantum and the lumbering
bastiodon pictured here locked in combat
and poses reminiscent of classic
dinosaur art not surprisingly palmer has
based his tyrantum off the t-rex and has
imagined its beard as a scaly soft
tissue pouch that could flare out to
intimidate rivals it's exciting to
imagine these creatures living in the
primordial landscape of the pokemon
world 100 million years ago it almost
makes me want to visit a pokemon museum
of natural history another fossil
pokemon you might find at such a museum
is that of aerodactyl now resurrected as
living creatures the aerodactyl are now
known by pokemon scientists to be a
vibrant shade of purple and to possess
early protofeathers on their necks
elsewhere in this image one can also
spot an arc hen and a cranny dose
further fleshing out the world of
prehistoric pokemon
deep in the midst of a past ice age the
mighty legendary pokemon qrem reigned
supreme here palmer has redesigned the
stylized armor of the original as more
biological plating though kyurem was a
creature of almost insurmountable power
the legendary beast raiku imagined here
as a smilodon like ice age hunter would
sometimes take the risk and try to
ambush this titan though a bite of a
raiku could take out most pokemon palmer
imagines it had less effect on
piloswines depicted in this image's ice
age megafauna with coats so thick they
provide a natural defense from the teeth
of whatever else might be stalking the
tundra
in modern polar and mountainous biomes
one might find the elusive obama snow
portrayed as a curious heavily furred
biped that palmer imagines were unknown
to pokemon scientists until the turn of
the century when a specimen was at last
documented sharing the frigid biosphere
with these seldom glimpsed creatures are
the elk-like pokemon winter sauce box
and the penguin-like deli bird another
life-form in this image is the infamous
mr mime reimagined as a species
somewhere between a frog and an axolotl
and honestly i find this redesign a bit
nicer to look at than the original
lurking in the cave systems one can find
neuvern a species that is a dragon type
in the games but palmer has
reconceptualized as a creature more
closely related to bat pokemon like
swoobats a single neuvern can claim
miles of cave systems as their territory
scaring off competitors with booming
sonic frequencies swoo bats are their
smaller cousins and look much closer to
a traditional bat here on earth and if
you look closely you can see jolticks
clinging to the fur of these species
palmer imagines these small arachnid
pokemon can create static charges by
nestling into the fur of other fluffy
pokemon pretty creative
one massive pokemon palmer redesigned is
onyx and its evolution stelix instead of
being made of literal rock onyx is
depicted as a massive serpentine
lifeform with rock-like scales likewise
a steelix isn't fully metallic instead
exposure to its natural environment
transforms its scales into shiny
metallic looking armor this process
almost reminds me of a scaly foot snail
a type of marine gastropod that
incorporates iron sulfide into
protective scales on its body almost
like a natural suit of medieval armor it
could see stelix perhaps undergoing a
similar process to form its own
protective scales in holding onto dear
life at the end of these creatures tales
you can perhaps spy a sable eye
reimagine not as a ghost but as a tiny
primate with strange eyes similar to
atazie palmer describes this species as
attracted to shiny objects which
unfortunately for this sable eye
included the metallic scales of a stelix
under the waves the aquatic leviathan
gyrados takes on the role of apex
predator in almost any aquatic ecosystem
they inhabit this creature recalls the
appearance of a deep sea or fish which
can grow up to 26 feet or 8 meters in
length smaller than this version of
gyrados but still pretty incredible
palmer imagines the marine biologists of
this world for decades didn't realize
the comparatively tiny magikarp were
early forms of gyrados which makes sense
in nearby a greater underwater ecosystem
flourishes including cloister and
aurelie camp all looking closer to the
real world animal influences
returning to legendaries we have the
awe-inspiring pokemon zapdos an enormous
bird with an incredible electric
discharge instead of being an elemental
deity this version of zapdos has an
extreme capacity for electricity
retention seeking out thunderstorms high
in the atmosphere and gathering
electricity like a living lightning rod
a very interesting reimagining another
electric pokemon is raichu the evolution
of pikachu that also looks quite
rodent-like as you might have already
spotted this image also contains voltorb
reimagined as a pokeball mimiking
armadillo and magnemites and magnatons
as magnetic crabs with red and
blue-colored claws in my opinion truly
hilarious designs for some of the most
outside the box and challenging original
pokemon another ancient and seldom scene
legendary is lugia redesigned as a
lifeform with more streamlined aquatic
features this guardian of the seas looks
like something from the pleisiasoria
order just even larger
near lugia are some additional
underwater species like quillfish and
sidra all of which have far more detail
than in their original designs
in the skies the immense legendary
yveltal redesigned here as an avian
super predator casts a dark shadow over
most flying types whenever it comes out
of its deep hibernation in designing
this ancient creature palmer took
inspiration from the late jurassic
feather dinosaur ichi an animal whose
wings are perhaps the closest thing
nature has ever produced to a dragons
swooping just out of reach of yuvitol's
claws are latios and latias with this
duo palmer has merged the stylized
airplane-like elements of the original
designs with the anatomy of various
real-life bird species creating more
plausible but still agile looking life
forms and in the other corner of this
image you can spot a scalier-looking
salamance whose wings according to
palmer are formed from membranes
extended over an enlarged set of ribs
this might seem far-fetched but
real-life draco lizards are capable of
gliding flight thanks to a set of wings
that are indeed supported by their
elongated ribs as you can see by this
skeleton
and since we touched on groudon in part
one we have to touch on its oceanic
counterpoint kyogre which looks
downright awe-inspiring in realistic
detail homer imagines this legendary as
a leviathan somewhere between a whale
and the absolute largest of marine
reptiles to capture prey kyogre can use
a dazzling bioluminescent display to
lure in smaller species like tentacruel
above the feeding kyogre a swarm of
frillish and jelly scent drift by their
anatomy much closer to that of an earth
jellyfish and if you look closely you
might have spotted sharpedo whose
stylized body has been reworked with a
design that takes inspiration from
sharks of course but also ocean sunfish
a strange and truncated looking organism
this sharpedo is going up against the
nautilus-like amistar another
prehistoric species that was recently
revived and as our grand finale we have
the mythical and legendary rayquaza
looking truly epic in realistic detail
this mighty serpent is exhibiting an
unknown display of bioluminescence as it
soars through the upper atmosphere a
site that would be intimidating to
behold exactly how such a creature is
capable of flight is unknown and would
likely require a variety of specialized
flight organs believe it or not there is
a type of snake called a paradise tree
snake that can glide for brief periods
by leaping off trees holding its body
flat and curving in a way which allows
it to coast through the air rayquaza of
course is taking this to a new level and
there's an entire aviary of flying types
flocking in rayquaza's shadow including
pidgeot braviary and others all of whom
look much more like birds you might see
here on earth
and with that we've covered the majority
of realistic pokemon in the project if
you want to dive even deeper into this
world there are extra designs including
some additional legendaries on rj
palmer's site and in his art books so
check the links below if you're
interested for now this is the final
part of the series but if you enjoyed
this entry please lend your support and
like subscribe and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things
curious see you in the next video